[Música]
francia asume la presidencia de turno
del consejo de la unión europea enmanuel
macrón plantea una europa más soberana y
con un modelo económico sostenible
ambientalmente el puesto podría
impulsarlo para las presidenciales de
abril
miles de partidarios de una alianza
iraquí de grupos armados conmemora en el
segundo aniversario del asesinato del
general qasem soleimani en un ataque
estadounidense el 3 de enero de 2020 el
líder de la fuerza quds era el brazo de
operaciones extranjeras de irak
en eeuu las autoridades tratan de
encontrar a tres personas desaparecidas
entre los escombros que dejaron los
voraces incendios en colorado alrededor
de 1000 viviendas quedaron destruidas en
el condado de voltaire
bienvenidos a este resumen informativo
en france 24 los saluda daniel hablan
con el presidente de francia de manuel
macro no ocupa a partir de este sábado
la presidencia rotativa de la unión
europea el mandatario afianza su
liderazgo antes de las elecciones de
abril tras el retiro de angela merkel
como canciller alemana y con la
presidencia temporal del consejo europeo
macrón anunció una agenda ambiciosa para
el bloque de 27 países que podría servir
para su campaña de reelección en francia
el grupo de contención pueden contar con
mi total compromiso para que este
período que ocurre es sólo cada 13 años
sea un tiempo de progreso una época de
avances hacia el control de nuestras
fronteras nuestra defensa la transición
climática la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres la construcción de una nueva
alianza con el continente africano un
mejor marco de plataformas de internet y
la cultura en europa
de fondón alternet y los valores que
lleva consigo nuestra unión europea y
democracia equilibrio entre libertad y
solidaridad una cierta noción de
humanidad estoy convencido que permitirá
estar a la altura de los desafíos de
nuestro tiempo
se le permitió el vino de cinco y miles
de integrantes de un grupo paramilitar
chiíta respaldado por irán salieron a
las calles de bagdad para conmemorar el
segundo aniversario del asesinato del
general iraní qasem soleimani tras un
ataque de un drone estadounidense en
[Música]
se niegan a olvidar la muerte del
general iraní qasem soleimani miles de
partidarios del grupo paramilitar chiíta
hasan shavit se reunieron en bagdad para
conmemorar el asesinato de suleman y el
líder iraquí a wood media handies
quienes perdieron la vida en el ataque
aéreo no tripulado de las fuerzas
armadas estadounidenses el 3 de enero de
2020 justicia por la sangre de los
mártires y la completa salida de las
fuerzas extranjeras en irak no aceptamos
nada menos no dejaremos de perseguir ese
objetivo y no dudamos las fuerzas
extranjeras deben salir completamente
del territorio iraquí debemos lograr la
completa soberanía nacional de irak
desde la invasión liderada por estados
unidos en 2003 que derrocó al dictador
suní saddam hussein el pueblo iraquí ha
pedido insistentemente que la presencia
extranjera en cualquiera de sus formas
se retire de su territorio este sábado
varias organizaciones de irak
respaldadas por teherán reunieron a sus
líderes chiíes en distintas ciudades
para enviar un mensaje claro a eeuu
y le decimos a los estadounidenses que
son unos ilusos si piensan que matando a
abul magd y al mojan dis ya qasem
soleimani le quitan la soberanía de irak
queremos decirles que eso es
completamente falso teherán por su parte
busca conservar su profunda influencia
en irak mientras mantiene tensas
negociaciones con las principales
potencias mundiales que buscan revivir
el acuerdo nuclear de irán de 2015 el
2022 se inició con nuevas tensiones
entre israel y palestina el ejército
israelí lanzó una ofensiva contra el
movimiento islamista hamás en el sur de
gaza el ataque se produjo después de que
dos cohetes fueran disparados desde el
enclave palestino el sábado por la
mañana cayendo al mar mediterráneo
frente a la costa de la vida el gobierno
de israel ha mantenido un bloqueo en la
zona desde 2007 año en el que el grupo
hamas tomó el poder
y en colorado por primera vez se habla
de personas desaparecidas en medio de
los voraces incendios que azotaron al
condado de boulder las autoridades
buscan entre los escombros a tres
personas que quedaron atrapadas en sus
hogares después de que un incendio
forestal quemara alrededor de 1000
viviendas en dos ciudades ubicadas al
noreste de denver la capital del estado
también se tratan de establecer las
causas de las conflagraciones que
rápidamente se extendieron por la región
dejando al menos 6 heridos
estamos investigando la causa y el
origen del incendio y si resulta ser un
incendio provocado ya sabes por un
comportamiento imprudente con el fuego
tomaremos las medidas adecuadas red
el día del incendio bandera roja por lo
que no debería haber existido en ninguna
quema de nada
y nuevamente tenemos informes de líneas
caídas por eso creemos que tal vez la
gente confundió las líneas de
telecomunicaciones que colgaban con las
líneas eléctricas shows
y en ese mismo país se sigue en pie el
juicio contra el príncipe andrés de
inglaterra
acusado en eeuu de abuso de menores un
juez de nueva york rechazó la petición
de su defensa de anular el proceso
judicial argumentando que esa corte no
tenía jurisdicción para llevar el caso
del que se llevara a cabo una audiencia
oral el próximo 4 de enero el
australiano estadounidense virgin sufría
denunció que fue víctima de tráfico
sexual por el fallecido jeffrey epstein
y su mano derecha gay maxwell y que a
raíz de ello sufrió abusos por parte del
príncipe andrés cuando tenía 17 años
pero un registro en 2021 una inflación
de 6 43% la más alta en los últimos 13
años e impulsada por los precios de los
combustibles según la oficina de
estadísticas este es uno de los efectos
económicos más visibles de la pandemia
en el último año pero no es el único
caso en la región
más temprano hablamos con josé guerrero
cusumano profesor de la escuela de
negocios de la universidad de georgetown
para conocer qué se puede esperar para
este año
los expertos tratan de ver en qué forma
inflación se va a mover evidentemente la
inflación va a depender de muchos
factores un factor muy importante que va
a suceder con el petróleo es el petróleo
y va a seguir aumentando las
proyecciones en el año
2022 para muchos de los especialistas
que son consultores dice que la
inflación va a empezar a bajar pero hay
algunos supuestos importantes un
supuesto que lo mejor no pensamos tanto
es en qué forma la economía china se va
a acelerar baja va a aminorar la
aceleración que tiene evidentemente
pensamos que el precio del petróleo en
este caso particular que está
relacionado a la inflación se va a
empezar a bajar ese precio posiblemente
en primavera pero también en septiembre
del año 2022 con respecto de inflación
tenemos que ver qué forma la cadena de
suministro global de ciertos productos
empiezan a mejorar la economía
estadounidense está fortaleciendo estos
trata trata evidentemente de ver en qué
forma los precios de esas como dispara
funcionar para bajar a subir
y lo más importante en este momento es
ver en qué formato beat va a evolucionar
influenciando a las cadenas de
suministro en la isla gorgona situada en
el suroeste de la costa pacífica
colombiana sufre los estragos de la
contaminación para proteger ese paraíso
tropical en la isla ya ha limitado las
visitas anuales pero parece no ser
suficiente para proteger este importante
corredor marítimo
es un pequeño paraíso que ya está
amenazado la isla gorgona una roca
volcánica cubierta de selva tropical
está situada en la costa pacífica del
sur occidente de colombia y es uno de
los puntos estratégicos para la
preservación de la fauna marina en la
región
gorgona es una isla mágica es un destino
místico por excelencia y el despertar de
las nuevas tendencias en el mundo
apuntan hacia este tipo de turismo por
supuesto la isla tiene mucho por ofrecer
el ecoturismo con la diversidad de
reptiles y serpientes lo que le dio el
nombre a la isla pero también su antigua
prisión cerrada en
1984 que fue famosa por hospedar a
prisioneros políticos y peligrosos
criminales del país era muy difícil que
los reclusos se escaparan de gorgona
porque
la isla estaba llena de reptiles
venenosos
muchas tarántulas venenosas y fuera de
eso las playas infectadas de tiburón
blanco pero gorgona es un sitio también
muy apreciado por los científicos a
pesar de los esfuerzos para proteger
este pedazo de eden y la voluntad de
regular el ecoturismo apenas 3.000
visitantes al año cada día sigue
llegando más contaminación humana en las
playas de la isla traída directamente
por el mar
y terminamos hablando de deportes como
es tradición comenzó este lunes este
sábado en arabia saudita del rally dakar
que va hasta el próximo 14 de enero el
qatarí nasser al-attiyah se impuso en la
categoría de autos en este primer
fragmento el español carlos sainz
terminó en la segunda posición a 12
segundos mientras que el francés
stéphane peterhansel vigente campéon
perdió un minuto y 12 segundos en los
quads venció el argentino manuel andújar
y en motos el chileno pablo quintanilla
cruzó la meta en la segunda posición
con estas imágenes nos despedimos una
feliz noche para todos
[Música]